william bonjour à vous on commence avec
une étude qui va faire beaucoup de bruit
une étude réalisée en suède qui établit
un lien très claire entre le risque du
cancer au cerveau et le téléphone
portable
selon ce document se restaurer trois
fois plus important en zone rurale que
dans les villes probablement pour des
raisons d'intensité du signal
explication julien machinerie utiliser
un téléphone portable serait plus
dangereux dans les campagnes que dans
les villes voilà une nouvelle qui va à
l'encontre des idées reçues
c'est une étude suédoise qui a révélé
ces conclusions surprenantes
les résidents de zones rurales s'étant
servi d'un portable pendant plus de
trois ans on est trois fois plus de
risques de développer une tumeur au
cerveau que ceux résidant dans les
villes ces différences proviendrait
peut-être du fait qu'à la campagne et
relais de transmission sont plus
éloignés les uns des autres et que donc
les rayonnements du téléphone placé
contre l'oreille serait plus fort pour
atteindre ces relais on l'avait déjà
constaté le téléphone portable à une
action sur le cerveau lors des
communications longue
plus important encore lorsque
l'utilisateur est jeune
reste que cette étude suédoise a encore
besoin d'être confirmée à une plus
grande échelle
elle ne concerne pour l'instant que 1400
personnes